I'm literally going to be in The Matrix
in two minutes
you gotta find me more time you gotta
stop five minutes hold on I'm hacking
into the Mainframe I've reached the
firewall almost got it
welcome to the trash taste podcast join
us as we dive into the world of
underrated overlooked and misunderstood
media from b-movies to forgotten albums
we'll be exploring the gems hiding in
plain sight and give them the
appreciation they deserve so whether
you're a connoisseur of trash or just
looking for something different this is
the podcast for you let's get started oh
my God you know what that's amazing we
need to use the term connoisseur of
trash
hello my well my fellow connoisseurs of
trash this episode is brought to you by
AI yes everything in this every topic of
this podcast is going to be AI related
uh because it's been a big generator
yeah generation we are not going to come
up with any topics of our own because
why would we have ai for that now so if
we want to go on a tangent the AI will
decide when we will go on the tangent uh
I guess I should um I crack open our
first top yeah yeah
jump right into it got a lot here in
trashcon all right so our first topic
for today is
anime dads The Good the Bad the Ugly
okay let me talk about the bad okay
[__] Goku all right can we talk about
how [__] of a dad Goku is did he like
raise his child at all I think you could
say this about most anime videos
just don't exist you know okay let's
Okay because there's so many bad anime
dads let's talk about the goat anime
dads first who are the like greatest
anime dads of all time the greatest
anime dads like I'm trying to think of
anime dad's icon
funny good anime that's I'm trying to
think who raised their child oh oh okay
okay it's a niche one but uh did you
ever watch sweetness and lightning yes
that's a golden anime dad I did not
watch that oh [__] you've just opened up
an entire do you remember that one yeah
yeah I remember that you've just opened
up an entire [__] door for me now
like [__] every everyone with a cute
little daughter like spy spikes family
yep I guess yeah
what's his name and it's my family uh uh
Lloyd Lloyd yeah Lloyd forger that's it
it's funny that they're like a fake
family and then they're more wholesome
than most like real anime they're more
put together than most families the
thing I found most unbelievable about
spy family is that he hasn't hit it yet
that's just like that's true that makes
no sense it's not part of the mission
Connor
I just want to spin off or it's just
like he gets a new Mission it's just
like breed
make more children it's like oh [__] I
need more children and make it more
convincing don't adopt it looks like I
have a pregnant wife it looks more
realistic oh honey I'm gonna get you
pregnant it's for the mission dude
sweetness and lining I remember the pot
that I [__] I mean well not the pie
just like the the thing that I
absolutely loved about that show have
you watched sweetness Delaney I have no
idea what that is okay so it came out a
few years ago obviously because I
watched it
um
but uh it's basically uh it's it's a
slice of life right basically yeah it's
a sex life show um essentially where uh
yeah there's a there's really cute like
I think she's like all the best ads are
in Slice of Life yeah to be honest it's
like this five five or six year old
daughter the mom is dead I mean it's
like it's literally it's not a spoil
it's literally the first scene the mom
is dead Okay um and it's basically a dad
trying to come to terms with uh raising
their only daughter but the daughter is
like really I guess like even though
she's super super young she's like I
think she's like four or five years old
or something right
um she like you know and obviously they
go through the hardships of like you
know being a single parent and stuff
like that and being a single dad but the
daughter is so [__] supportive and
wholesome to the dad that every dude who
watched that show was just like I want a
daughter like you you are like The
Golden Child of children that I want to
have and it's it's just so [__] good
you just you've just reminded me of
something yeah the I think I think the
manga or show that started this entire
like wholesome dad daughter relationship
Trend I'm talking about good Dads What
About usagi Drop oh
I never watched I mean it's good
look good is uh good is a subjective too
uh he's a great dad at the beginning
super degenerate dad near the end okay
so I'm gonna spoil usagi drop it's
[__] I'm never gonna watch it it's
years old if you haven't watched usagi
drop I doubt you would watched it yeah
uh I doubt this is going to change
anything now but uh okay soggy drop the
anime [__] great you see this
wholesome father-daughter relationship
where I can't remember the exact concept
of it but I believe the daughter is like
um he adopts this daughter
uh and it's the anime is this
exploration of you know him learning how
to be a dad and kind of like fathering
this uh adoptive daughter and uh
learning feelings and stuff and then it
goes on learning feelings learning some
wholesome feelings really nice I'm not
gonna watch it yeah and then uh people
went on to read the Manga which was you
know it was very very wholesome until
like kind of kind of like the ending uh
because uh obviously because the manga
is way more longer running than the
anime went uh the daughter grows up
and uh
she uh discovers that uh she has
developed feelings
for her adopted father yeah
why can't we get anything that's normal
basically basically the Creator I think
read or emo and went yeah
they just become [__] weird because
the thing is this was a really like
unironically like a wholesome innocent
show it was a really good show
wholesome and innocent about this
father-daughter relationship the ending
comes and you're like no please don't
you have to question the state of the
author yeah you'd be like what's
happening in your head what was going on
with this this felt like the right
storyline you know what like something
like this I could accept if it was like
a hentai or something yeah you know I
can accept that I've seen worse things
in hentai but don't give me like every
every other [__] other stepmother is
like [__] their childhood that's
different all right
you wouldn't get it but like don't give
me like 10 volumes of some of the most
cute yeah
family coming-of-age story and then just
turn around and be like what if I what
if we just like made it official yeah
but in a completely different relation
relationship yeah and everyone was like
because I remember reading the manga as
well because I I I watched the anime
first and I was like this is great but I
heard there was a continuation yeah and
so I was like all right sick I bought
all the volumes reading it I'm like okay
this is great super cute and then it
literally happens in like the last maybe
four or five chapters okay and I'm just
like
yeah is this like a spinner fire red
like what happened because because the
worst part is right because at first
it's just like the daughter like
realizing her feelings and you're like
please don't please don't let this be
like the ark and the Direction the Story
is going uh I I think the the moment
where I kind of like just threw the
manga on the floor was just when okay
the daughter is [__] young she don't
know what the [__] she's doing yeah but
then like the father accepts it as well
I'm like no no you're meant to be the
mature one here the one time you had to
be an adult you were just like nah so
it's secretly a big debate for grooming
yeah yeah you're getting love it's just
one big group it's one big grooming
motor unfortunately uh yeah so we've
decided to do a you know uh telling of
the priest story uh from the side of the
priest where he's become you know like
yeah he's just like what okay
um a good dad is Aaron Jaeger's dad a
good dad
do you believe that there are some kids
that are just doomed from the beginning
where it doesn't matter how good the
dead could be where the child is just a
spawn of Satan yeah do you believe that
that exists yeah yeah I'd say so would
you say irony falls into that most
likely I'd say this is uh complicated
we can make this entire podcast of was
Aaron Yeager right
disgusters just have the fortnite meme
it's fortnite okay Karen Yeager was
never wrong also I don't want to spoil
it people who haven't watched it yeah
yeah another another character that I'll
pitched you is Kirito's dad a good dad
Kirito's dad even though he wasn't there
but is he a good dad for raising Kirito
oh like how like how so he turned out as
Kirito is that like did he do the job
are you talking about Kirito's dad or
Kirito as a dad Kirito's Dad wait oh
yeah Kirito was a dad too yeah
Dad who adopted with uh uh yui with uh
[__] Arsenal right I blocked that
from my videos
because that's the moment where so I
went to [__] very early on yeah very
early on yeah Kirito has a dad did you
know that did you know that does he
actually make an appearance yeah really
is he good
um wait when huh when in alicization Oh
okay that's why
because spoiler I've actually been
watching someone that's online I've
actually because I actually had this
realization the other day that um I've
watched every piece of like Sword Art
Online media that has been released in
anime
um
yeah it was weird because at the end of
alicization there's a moment where
Kirito has a scene with his mother and
father to be like I think I know what to
own what I want to be and what I want to
pursue growing up and I'm like [__] me
it took 70 like 100 [__] episodes to
get to this point what the [__] we're
actually doing this now what are this
problem
what kind of parents are there they're
normal parents of course they are
actually they were just like can you
please decide what the [__] you want to
do with your life piss your life away
with video games I know you're like an
epic gamer but please choose a career
path I'm like you know what I can I I
can actually kind of respect that
someone had to say it someone had to be
like you to uh being a beta is not a
viable career option I'm sorry it's not
a thing yeah actually there's one scene
at the end of alicization where his
mom's just like next time you go into a
[__] game that could like kill you
can you like tell us first like this is
the third time this has happened are you
please just [__] tell us what do you
doing just find a better way to end it
like okay do you know how we had to
explain to the doctors when we had to
carry you into the hospital with a
[__] gaming headset on yeah you can't
like you get to you get addicted to VR
chat once again I can understand the
third [__] time happened you almost
died from this and you don't tell us
this [__] please tell us oh my God
actually actually like on comes a VR
chat mute yeah yeah and like when he's
40. yeah on the topic of like usagi
dropping like degenerate dads and stuff
like that there's that I remember like
recently there was an anime that was
just the opposite of that I think okay
um I think the anime was called like
Higa Hiro and I really oh yeah I really
really hope that the manga hasn't gone
some Saucy Roots right well I mean it's
originally a light novel so it's
probably going down gonna go down the
Saucy road because the the thing that I
liked about that was it's a show where a
guy basically picks up this runaway like
middle school high school girl and
literally the start to every hand yeah
yeah and you'll and you watch the first
episode and you're like this is uh this
is this is very very sus yeah this is I
I I've seen enough hentai snow where
this is going
um and then it turns out every time like
the girl tries to be even remotely
sexual he's just like get away from your
child I do not I am not interested in
children and I'm just like man is this
the standard we have an anime where
someone's saying yeah yes someone's
saying no child get away from me I do
not find you interesting uh that's
that's like commendable now again no I
was just like damn this is a really this
is a really original route that this uh
this anime has gone down to be fair it
kind of is like and that's kind of the
sad thing right it's like if you see an
otaku like resist that oh it's just like
oh wow all right he gets [__] oh all
right he's different you mean he's
picking up this uh he's he's picking up
his Runway high school girl just to help
her just just just to be lucky that
doesn't just to be a Good Samaritan yeah
and then the girl was like why are you
gay I don't think that's a good dad is
Subaru's dad from Reserve good dad I
think he's pretty good right he's not in
the show yeah he has a motivational
moment with him he's like come on kid
don't suck I was like
yeah it was like in your mind though
wasn't it yeah maybe it wasn't his mind
but is that does that count as a dad if
it's a dad it's like an imaginary attack
what if the imaginary dad has more
impact on your life than the real dad
okay that's true who are the worst dads
in anime oh that's [__] go man uh
Shinji shinji's dad gendo that's the
yeah he's like the go-to I aspire to be
a dad what about the just like just
confidently that bad like I just hate my
kid that much like that's almost
impressive that he committed that hard
to it he was only one step away from you
know looking at xinji being like who
like like I would say he he committed so
much to being a bad dad that he was
always around which is more than some
other bad dads right which I think is
it's kind of gaslighting Shinji right
it's like no I'm here for you but
beginning to get in the robot I mean the
other the other uh the other
stereotypical bad dad is a Nina's dad
from formal Alchemist obviously I know I
know what you're talking about yeah I
don't know whatever his name I'm trying
to think of some Devil's Advocate where
I can I could argue he's a good dad
I would love to hear this okay the AI
would be great okay okay so
um actually a good dad okay let me let
me break it down for you okay let me
break it down for you is there anything
more pure in life than a dog yeah he
wanted her to be a good boy forever yeah
how do you keep your children pure and
innocent forever okay you cross them
with a dog okay that's I I have not seen
Full Metal Alchemist but I'm guessing
that was his motivation and you know
what I kind of dig with it man you know
what you know what daughters overrated
dogs though look that [__] sticks with
you look I bet that daughter would have
grown up to be a [__] to be a [__]
Turd Man okay every daughter reaches
that age in in that teenage hood you
know when they're just like Dad I don't
care about you you're stinky get the
[__] yeah
want that you know I think he was just
like oh you're about to hit puberty not
on my watch
um I asked it to why is Nina's dad from
Fullmetal Alchemist right and he goes
the series does not depict any character
of the perspective of right or wrong
yeah that shouldn't have consequences
and they make mistakes as well the story
doesn't shy away from showing characters
flaws
I mean that's an interesting defense
that's an interesting defense yeah like
I'm with God in this Camp you just want
to make a good boy yeah fair enough and
was the dog a little sad yeah but yeah
that those could be sad we just don't
hear them you know it's a work in
progress I think imagine if he actually
perfected though and the dog is happy
when it happens then I think science
maybe yeah exactly maybe he's the
uncomfortable questions
maybe he's the victim maybe he was like
I just wanted to make a good boy and
then it ended up being a sad dog he was
a scientist helping us yeah because this
was his first attempt at it you know and
you know every scientific breakthrough
has a few failures every now and again
you know are we gonna say no to human
experimentation just because a few
people get violently murdered I don't
know I don't know he's just like all
right
here
it's like wife I need another daughter
we need another one this experiment went
wrong don't don't ask I'm really
actually now the lack of dads in anime
there's not a lot there's a lot of good
Dads Mecca definitely does not have a
good track record but somebody Just
Dance aren't around I mean just just I
mean like like think about it
perspective right it's just like what
every every Mecca dad just wants to
[__] take over the world be a shitty
dad well think about it even in like you
know in the defense of like gendo for
instance like he was a good dad to Ray
he was a [__] tab to Shinji though I
would argue he was a good husband
already oh yeah yeah Dad slash husband
it all goes back I can't think of any
other dads I'm just I'm looking around I
okay if we're not if there's so many
moms we're not talking about anime
specifically or like I guess things that
came from and to anime like say if like
Pokemon right the Pokemon series oh you
never see Ash's dad I I got one right
what about rudius's dad from Ashoka
tense though
with the when he gets reincarnated yeah
yeah one week
I like him he's got he's he's like a
floor little Playboy yes a little
Playboy yeah I like it I think he's a
good dad I think he's he's one of the
most human dads I've seen he's a bit of
a scumbag but yeah he also is a good dad
so it makes him a lot more believable as
a character he like tries to be a good
dad like I think the scene that got me
in michokotensei uh was the scene where
rudius like hugs him to be like I wasn't
the perfect dad and he's just like I
forgive you I was like oh [__] man I
wish I could tell my dad that sometimes
okay okay question ask a lad uh racing
well I'll tell you about his son but
basically yeah yeah yeah it's just like
the same side yeah yeah he's the best
stepdad yeah you know the best case
scenario kills your real dad yeah and
then becomes the goat dad like like
obviously killing the real dad is bad
but if he becomes an even better Dad I
think there's a there's a question to be
but he went he went into it he went into
it than Alpha mentality he was like I'm
gonna kill your real dad because I'm
more confident I could be a better dad
than your real dad that's why he's the
ugly but good Dad yeah yeah okay and
he's Welsh
so you know he's the best Welsh dad
we've had yet okay
yes is Minato a good dad to Naruto
is Naruto a good dad is Naruto a good
dad as well double question Naruto
Naruto neither Naruto or Sasuke are good
dads [__] like obviously Sasuke is
obviously everyone to be have a kids
anyway Sasuke went out to get milk and
never came back he was that he was that
Dad man I feel so sorry for what was her
name like sarada or whatever yeah
you know you're a bad dad because you
name your daughter [__] sour Sasuke's
the kind of dude who felt like he would
try and explain to you for 10 minutes
why he took the condom off right before
he put it in you know what I mean like
he would have he would have a full-on
conversation trying to justify it to you
yeah that's the vibe he gives off yeah
the only the only part of boruto I've
seen is for like the new narrator movie
so I'm not like up to date yeah to like
boruto so I don't know how good of a dad
narrator is now but my [__] god he
needs to learn how to discipline his kid
man [__] me man he's out of [__]
control he is man
barter's a dick you know it's so weird
because like see I I forget the bar is
not even an only child but everyone
forgets like she has a sister because
her sisters her sister's so well behaved
right and Naruto's definitely that Dad
was that was just like I was a [__]
[__] when I was a kid so you know
what kid you can be a [__] too and
I'm like no Naruto don't do that my dad
wasn't there during my childhood I won't
be for you either I'm learning by
example you think you'd think from not
having like not not growing up with
parents that narrator would want to like
offset that and be a really good [__]
parent and be there for his kids he does
he doesn't learn from that you'd think
he would know that I guess anime
normally has father figures as opposed
to fathers yeah straight up I don't know
I guess
I guess choose your own dad I guess
that's it yeah and that was that was the
anime dads The Good the Bad and the Ugly
this is this is literally so you can
pick one okay next one uh go for it
let's go to tangent next to the the what
uh sorry guys that that brings me that
makes me think about uh food that sounds
disgusting but actually delicious
that sounds disgusting food s don't
throw this down but it says food that
sounds disgusting but actually delicious
um see there's two ways we can go about
it the name sounds disgusting but it's
actually good or the concept sounds nice
I think should be the concept that
sounds disgusting if you say [__]
shirako I'm I'm leaving Joey that that
sounds disgusting and it is disgusting
oh that's delicious as well I will not
take Shino going up or slander from you
to non-japanese people
uh there's a lot of Japanese foods that
are like that like I'm just thinking
most Japanese food I okay okay okay okay
one for me that I I actually saw by like
real life example was when I first uh
brought a couple of my like Australian
high school friends to Japan right and
they were the kind of like super like
Western friends who like never tried you
know proper like Japanese food or like
any kind of Asian food and I took them
to eat skiaki okay right and they
thought the concept of the raw egg was
disgusting yeah it is a hot salad Jackie
is like a like a meaty broth where you
cook all the veg like a hot pot but so
you cooked all the veg and the meat in
the top part but what makes it unique is
that you have a raw egg on the side that
you whisk kind of to make it all uh like
consistent yeah then you dunk everything
in this broth in the raw egg then eat it
yeah it's really good yeah but it sounds
kind of gross yeah you know you don't
cook the egg before you cook the meat
and then dunk the cooked meat in the raw
egg Yeah so basically the meat and the
vegetables are like kind of sounds gross
yeah yeah it's been simmering in this
like so we saw space broth and now
there's just like a whole bunch of raw
egg over it it sounds gross if you've
never had it but when you have it you
realize it's one of the best types of
hot pots you can have in Japan it is
delicious I don't know the the yolk it
just it's a natural sauce yeah right and
what what are you gonna say yeah sorry I
just had a bad thought come on
I'm just gonna say the yog just makes
such a delicious natural sauce that we
just have never had before yeah but when
I think about it it's like okay I think
to a lot of people conceptually that's
quite gross yeah yeah even though it's
pretty just pretty delicious uh so I
propose yeah the toast sandwich
is that okay
it's not great it's just nothing it's
just blind it's pretty good that's like
saying I like the taste of it
get the [__] out of here corner okay
what are you talking about that is the
whitest thing you've said on this
podcast I've had it I thought it sounded
dumb as [__] and I had it and I thought
it's not that bad it's pretty good okay
so explain so it's it's basically is it
a sandwich that has toast in it it's
yeah so it's two pieces of bread yeah
like toasted non-toasted bread
non-toasted bread and then you have a
toasted bread in the middle that you
normally season with salt and pepper and
then you put it just like in the middle
and you eat it it's pretty good you can
put butter on if you want to it's pretty
good it sounds gross but I would rather
just have [__] toast you know why why
am I feeling this why why am I filling
myself up with two extra slices of
non-toasted bread when I could also too
though it's different it's good
you should try it we should all try it
what what compelled you to make this
thing well because I I had seen it so
many times and I thought well [__] it
I'll just try it like I just I before I
make my opinions on it yes it sounds
[__] stupid I did to be fair when we
were pretty good we were in the UK last
year I did go to like a bakery and I did
see it on their menu and I was really
short on the menu I've never seen it
I've seen I've seen it on the menu [__]
and it was like I never seen it on
demand I saw it on a menu and I was like
that that can't be right I'm misreading
this British Cuisine let's put bread
between us
we're going to use this to slant my
taste buds but hey it's not bad you've
got to try it before you you deny it I
didn't I didn't love it enough as it is
Connor why didn't you tell me salt bread
carbs and just black pepper is just all
I need like that's good enough for me
I'm like a I'm like a I'm like a you
know how like dogs you give them dog to
treat every single day give them the
exact same [__] thing yeah how do you
how do they get so excited every time
right that's what I want for my food
well that's also because their brains
are smaller is that why yes if they had
bigger brains
again yeah so they're just less
incapable of being like um actually I've
had this for 200 days straight faster uh
I require some other type of sustenance
they don't have that knowledge
I'm slandering the bread sandwich but
you know what Chris toast sandwiches
toast sandwich crisp sandwich I actually
get behind that I like Christmas time
just I don't know does it sound
disgusting though is it it's just like
socially looked downable and I don't
know why because seen as a peasant food
it's seen as a peasant food and I don't
know why it should be seen as a delicacy
[__] if they said Yeah
dance securing his British citizenship
for Life
they're never they're never that like
they'd never be in question no you know
why kids on a playground getting bullied
for bringing a crisp sandwich to school
let's not pretend that it's not like the
best meal we could have as a kid that
you it's the meal that you wanted as a
kid but you couldn't tell your parents
foreign
like chip sandwiches
yes I love chip sandwiches
fries yeah like hot chips I love those
love those pretty good I could I could
possibly uh that was that was like that
was my diet maybe some mail or something
too for us in Australia we've got some
chicken salt on that [__] okay another
thing that definitely sounds disgusting
and isn't that bad I'd say is well maybe
not delicious you'd probably agree I
think you'd say horses oh horse meat
horse sounds disgusting yeah
I don't think it's that it sounds
disgusting I think it sounds it's just
morally wrong yeah it's a lot of people
right it's like eating like cat or dog
yeah right it's like it's it's not about
like
moral I wouldn't say it's on that level
but an animal that we have let's say
domesticated and have put to use but
with domesticated horses no no exactly
no no I'm I'm but like horses haven't
been domesticated on as wide of a like
level as not not white as well it's not
as wide spread as people owning cats and
dogs right it used to be pretty
widespread oh he used to be widespread I
have no doubt I don't think they did
they eat it back then I have no idea I'm
not maybe maybe in Japan they did yeah
probably Japan they've always been
eating yeah man it's like doesn't move
we need it I had a there's this
um the seal sound disgusting it's seal
I'd seal in a can that just sounds like
oh I I think I have as well it's just
it's the very blubbery right yeah and
like very fatty it's like uh bear meat
as well it wasn't very good yeah like
does bear meat sound disgusting yeah
you sound disgusting and he like any
like apex predator I just feel is just
doesn't taste just shouldn't taste good
like crocodile
crocodile I've never had crocodile
before I've had crocodile it's like it's
like tough chicken
tough chicken it is it's like tough
chicken it close your eyes does that
sound disgusting yes and I think they
are disgusting I actually from the
[__] delicious holy [__] frog legs I
can't actually they just like and they
just like they just like baby chicken
legs I can't eat it without picturing
that frog dancing
with the top hat hello my baby when have
you had frogs I had it when I was in
France oh okay yeah I did too and it
came on a plane I was like oh [__] it's
that boy
I just said I just imagined happy
singing and dancing like 20 minutes ago
I don't know why what's wrong with my
brain oh yes okay frogs no but horses
yeah I'll [__] eat yeah
I'm not a horse person so I don't care
about are you a frog person I kind of
like frogs
frogs are cute as [__] it's not cute
okay what about escargot I was going to
say now that we're on the escargon you
know I guess Gaga I'm not a fan I quite
like it why does God look so stunned by
me saying that
I was just no I wasn't stunning I was
like why why am I not surprised that
Joey's like yeah that was delicious it's
great Joey likes everything weird
depends on my mood because sometimes I
you know we don't we don't want to admit
it but our mental image of something uh
can affect the texture you know it's
it's if you associate a food or drink
it's like a bad time or a bad experience
it also is worse as well yeah yeah
exactly like I've had escargot and I I'm
fine with the taste I I'm never going to
like go out and look for it uh but I'm
I'm not like opposed to it but when I
know it's escargot I I know that there's
this part of my brain that is just like
you're eating a [__] slimy ass snake
is it isn't it weird okay in that in
that vein isn't it also weird that we're
totally okay with eating snails but
we're not okay with eating slugs
well I mean okay I've always thought I'm
not okay with it either of them okay
yeah I'm not okay why did you assume we
are okay with eating slow I think like
as in like we're okay with eating snails
but we're not okay with eating I always
found the snails
Society again snails with a more refined
slugs I always thought they were the
classier slugs you know they just the
Slugs that live in Caravans all right
yeah yeah yeah it's like the broke the
broke snail is the slide right like it's
like you know like snails are like
snails it's not you know looks uh slugs
are just like snails that have gone
through like the home uh
homeless crisis you know
they ain't Rich enough to buy a home
they're obviously
I had one [__] I had it I forgot it um
it was
um what
[__] I forgot it okay what kind of
things is there any animal body part to
you that sounds disgusting uh testicles
testicles yeah I've had I've had I've
had like balls testicles before
um conceptually I was like all right I'm
eating nuts um yeah you know that's
whatever but but I'm very much in the
mindset of like you know whatever it
might be conceptually as long as it
tastes good yeah and I'm okay with it
for the most for me I'd actually because
I I think I'd actually rather eat a
testicle
um than even out of contact yeah yeah
I'd rather eat a testicle like
conceptually right yeah I know something
about eating like a blood vessel or a
blood vessel so like like like black
sausage like a vein or something like oh
a vein because because I've seen that
before you can eat veins yeah uh it's
like a blunt like a vein on artery or
something right
it's I I've seen that before and I'm
just like how do they get it out intact
what do you mean like like usually it's
like quite you know they're quite small
right so do they just pull up well some
of like the main big arteries oh I see I
see I like you know it's pretty pretty
[__] fat something about something
about something about that just like
freaks me the [__] out and I'm like like
eating God yeah okay something that
sounds conceptually disgusting yeah fish
eggs
fish eggs look and sound disgusting when
you before you've had them and then you
try it you're like oh they're quite
refreshing sure yeah if you'd never had
fish eggs like and you've no you don't
have a culture of eating them and
someone had said hey can you want to eat
fish eggs like my parents were like I
told them that and they were like oh
like is that like caviar I'm like yeah
yeah it's caviar but different well
caviar is fish eggs yeah well it's like
it's in like the oh like salmon the
normal common fish eggs that you eat
yeah fish eggs are [__] delicious
yeah
um I remember some like because uh
whenever like in Thailand uh whenever
there's like you know if you fry the
fish sometimes the fish eggs sometimes
they don't remove the fish eggs from the
fish
yeah so so you open it up and it's just
like packed it's just like looking out
huh oh that's good it's delicious and
it's one of the most delicious parts of
the fish I think because it's fried it
absorbs all of the sauces that you fried
in I think they're both separate now I'm
realizing I like them what they I don't
see the eggs from the fish I like that I
just see the eggs but that's weird
though
it's no different right it's just it's
just separated yeah yeah that's like
being like Oh I like sausages and I like
mashed potatoes but I don't like bangers
and mash it's the equivalent to that I
think I did just seeing you know
sometimes everyone always says like how
the sausage is made yeah yeah it's like
I I see how the sausage is made and I
don't mind that I'm like that's that's
fine but when I see where the eggs come
from like oh yeah oh that's weird yeah
like when I see those videos where they
open up the sturgeon to get the caviar
yeah and they just [__] rip this
thing's stomach open like a doom like
video and then grab all these hundreds
of thousands of eggs
you're just watching a C-section man
yeah yeah that's basically what you want
but it comes in the tin I don't question
it and I'm like that's nice yeah that's
cool but it's all about packaging but
when it comes directly they've ripped it
out I'm like whoa that's a lot yeah I
think caviar is like overrated anyway I
don't like caviar yeah and I was like
this is [__] it's pretty overrated it's
it's the same as any other ingredient
you can't just slap it onto anything and
just hope they taste good because people
just [__] add it to the menu to to
make it more expensive yeah I know I
don't think anyone actually cares about
the flavor yeah because it's just salt
it is it's just it's just a little salt
and uh it's it's a little bit of salt
and a little bit of like sea and like
fishy fish yeah sea water flavor salt
yeah it's just very yeah that's it it's
just very expensive sea water let's be
honest right that's that's what it is oh
my God that can taste good but uh
definitely not worth the price uh that
you picked I think I was a weird kid I
think I remember I liked the taste of
the sea salt like the the sea like I
think I got it on me and I licked like
my I had like a wristband on or
something I licked it I don't know why I
don't know why I'm licking everything I
think I licked it I was like damn this
[__] tastes good I know it does taste
whenever it is
it tastes so good in the ocean have you
have you never gone like swimming oh
then it dries out and then your Skin's
like all like flaky because of the salt
yeah like oh that tastes good like when
you actually get it in your mouth and
you're like you're like I'm not gonna
tell you on this but it tastes really
[__] good that tastes good because
there's no other undoubtedly amount of
sewage in this and I'm not gonna say
that yeah yeah because because like I
remember when I was a kid in Thailand we
had like we owned like a bunch of dogs
at our house and my grandma did every
time we'd go to our trip to the seaside
we'd come back and the dogs were just
like [__] repet them and we'd Pat the
dogs on the dogs would like lick the
[__] out of my hands like oh yeah I know
where they're like
speaking of I just thought of a tangent
oh yeah uh what about the etiquette and
taboos of pooping in different cultures
Howie what did you put it in this AI to
get these problems uh I just I put in uh
give me talking points about a podcast
uh that talks about Japan anime pooping
and everything else here's the pooping
one so the Attica in Japan uh you have
to take your shoes off in some places
like you have to wear a different pair
of shoes oh yeah yeah you'll be in a
restaurant where you've taken off your
shoes and go into the toilet if you wear
another pair of slippers yeah the
communal toilet slippers yeah do you
ever use the communal toilet slippers
hell no oh hell no
but it's kind of nasty when you think
about it it is like I'd rather just take
my risks and touch the floor because
yeah because like think about like the
amount of first of all like not clean
like socks and potentially you know just
feed that appear yeah and then second of
all in the case with guys right like
think of the amount of like piss that
just [__] flings out and lands on the
slippers right and I don't know how
often they're cleaning these slippers I
assume not very often yeah in some
places right but but there have been so
like it's it's it's a time for me
normally I don't use it but there's
sometimes I walk in a toilet and I see
like a small little wet patch somewhere
and I'm like yeah sure I am taking the
chance I ain't taking the chance yeah
yeah that's the only time I would wear
if but if like the toilet looks clean
and there's like no noticeable puddles
or anything then I'm just I'm just going
in with my socks yeah is there a culture
in Japan because I don't I don't know
and I'm asking um against like because
in the UK and I think the us as well
there's kind of um I think it's mainly
the UK people really don't want to [__]
in public like they [__] in a public
toilet is like a is that culture I don't
know if it's culture I think it's an
individual thing I know a lot of people
who really will do anything to not [__]
I'm that person okay I am that person is
this yeah cause I I are you calling me
Al Corner you're saying like I I know
you probably know a lot of people who
are like the same right yeah is it the
same in Australia as well or is it
um yes only because uh unlike Japan the
public toilets is disgusting they're a
bit more disgusting but I'm also a lot
more forgiving I use [__] because I'm
kind of the mindset of okay I'm in the
mess okay there's there's I'm part of
the mess there's a lot of reasons why I
wanna [__] right in my the comfort of my
own I will never want to [__]
let's take like let's say hygiene out of
it let's assume we live in Japan yeah a
country where the public toilets are
clean as [__] okay sometimes sometimes
sometimes sometimes you see some gnarly
toilets here yeah I don't know like my
Japan's track record for public toilets
compared to every other country I've
been to it's really [__] yeah I'll
say that
um so taking that aspect out of it uh
there's one there's just you know
sometimes there's just something
comforting about [__] in a place
that's your own home okay because okay
do you feel uncomfortable [__] in
your mate's place no ah yeah in fact I
try and do it every time I go to my
mate's house what the [__] okay what's
wrong
that's the last time I
want to mark my territory I think I got
I I don't like it I think you had this
one time in your house car I don't know
if you still do yeah you had the fur
thing on your toilet oh yeah that freaks
me out it's like the last thing the
carpet on the last thing I want to
picture is carpet and [__] like I want
it to be like porcelain so that if I
[__] everywhere it's super easy to wipe
now just a thought of
rubbing my ass cheeks against a carpet
well I'm gonna [__] I'm like oh oh yeah
that's that's a little strange
because in Japan they have you can get
the carpet on top of the toilet yeah I
have the carpet on top of the leaves
yeah that's pretty normal but then some
people some monsters have the carpet on
the like actual part you sit on yeah
yeah and that's where I'm like it's a
bit weird
I think I'll just followed my wife on
that one I won a game I woke up one day
and I'm just like why would you do this
what is this what is this I had to I had
to just get used to it because like my
grandma had it my whole life so I'm just
kind of used to it now but I not but in
saying that I don't like it I I like
that we have certain rules in society
that we don't change certain things and
the design of the toilet has gone
unchanged for generations and I don't
think we should start rethinking it I
think the toilet is a banger let's just
stick with it it's like this is why I
hate it when dudes wear like when it's
in a formal event and everyone's wearing
a ticket and a guy wears something other
than a tuxedo it's like okay what are
you trying to do here you're trying to
[__] with the norm you're everyone has a
social contract we know the tuxedo is
the go-to we all know that we can just
whip out the tuxedo and we're taken care
of it's fine don't start changing the
norm don't change the toilet okay here's
the question then if you're out in
public right yeah and and this applies
mostly to people who are comfortable
with shitty in public AKA Connor yeah
right but so you're in a situation and
I'm sure you've been in a situation like
this because I certainly have you'll you
ha you have to take a [__] like you
can't hold it in right yeah but that's
fine you're okay with public shooting in
public right you walk in and there are
only the Japanese style toilers do you
take a [__] if I gotta go I gotta go
I've never done it though I've never
shout in a Japanese style toilet which
is um as long as you just squat over a
whole yeah the squat toilets yeah I've
avoided it thus far have you have you
ever shown in Japanese style toilet
before oh I mean yeah I mean we have
those all the time in Thailand right
um
basically at every gas station it's it's
awful
um
how do you avoid splashback
in what
in the standing toilets because you're
dropping it like that that's gaining
some G's that [__] like you ain't
dropping it that far mate wait what are
you standing up what are you doing how
far
no no the real question is at what
velocity does this [__] leave your ass
so much so that is splashing bro if I'm
dying and I'm using one of those toilets
it's probably a pretty vicious Force
that's coming out so how low are we
getting when we're shooting are we like
we're getting we're all like like knees
are like fully bent like this yeah knees
in a Japanese team yeah yeah no you're
like fully squatty yeah I thought it was
like a 90 degree kind of mean situation
are you just imagine just Conor has seen
the squad totally it's like all right
[Music]
it's just like dropping it for like
sushi I've never tried and I I don't I
don't dare try it Conor just like takes
his trousers off and just stands on top
of the toilets
how do they get back up do people like
just get stuck no because they're
probably they have probably have to do
it every day no I've seen some old
people in Japan who can barely like walk
around oh they probably own Western
toilets in that case they're too damn
straight they do yeah you need that's I
think that's why every Asian is like
pre-programmed in their Gene to be able
to Asian school yeah just in case it
needs to [__] in a public toilet okay
here's another question when it comes to
Etiquette okay okay
um again this doesn't apply to you right
it applies to you though when you [__]
in a public toilet right Western one do
you use the bidet yes okay because I
know a lot of people who don't okay so
because it's like why would I share a
bidet with some random well I'm fine
with sharing a bit because like because
the way the bidet comes out right it
comes out like like this angle right and
the bidet shoots the water that way yeah
so there's no way it could get dirty and
even if it did it's like well it's no
more dirty than just putting your ass
cheeks on the toilet anyway that's
exactly and you're already washing it
with water so let's say even if there
was a tiny bit of dirt left on the bidet
somehow yeah it would get blown away
anyway from all the ass washing you're
doing right yeah I feel like that's like
a weird mind-blowing but I I know a few
people who have that mindset and I've
told them that exact same thing they're
like no it's still like if you're
willing to put your cheeks on the same
seat that like 1 000 plus other people
have put their cheeks on yeah and some
people are pretty good on it dirty as
well like I'm I feel like you have no
yeah like uh I think you'll find at that
point it's like whatever at that point
you use the Japanese
do you know one of like the scariest
sights to see in like a public toilet in
my mind like so so you need a [__] right
someone just goes out of the toilet
stall you go in and you see that they
put like the toilet lid down and you're
like oh [__] you have to touch it oh
he's he's just dropped a fat one because
you know what I mean because every time
that happens because you never like when
you go to a public toilet like do you
put the toilet seat down afterwards no
as in like after you take a [__] no no
uh no you I I only do that when I know
I've dropped a [__] stinker oh like a
like a [__] nuclear bomb every time I
walk in a toilet store and I see the
toilet seat it's like fully down I'm
like someone's just [__] destroyed
this toilet and I don't know if I'm
emotionally prepared for me I'm more
scared of even though I just heard the
flush yeah I walk in and I see the lid
is closed somewhere deep in my mind I'm
like if I open this I'm gonna see that
guy's turn
he's left me a nasty [__] surprise
that I'm not ready to open this I'm not
ready to open this Pandora's box but I
need to it's the smell because I know as
soon as I open it it's just like I know
I'm gonna [__] smell it's gonna be a
bomb it's gonna be a bomb I know I'm
gonna hit me hit with that wave of smell
and I'm like oh God why can't I I've
just waited like 10 more minutes but a
smell to dissipate but oh yeah that's uh
nasty do you use that weird like toilet
seat outline sheet you can get at some
toilets
um sometimes I do occasionally if it's a
really nasty looking toilet I'll try but
I guess so frustrating because it never
stays on the [__] seat yeah yeah you
know what I'm talking about yeah you can
get these like kind of toilet paper
style things that kind of go around the
whole toilet and then you poke out it's
like a serviette for a toilet weird and
it's so fidgety and it never stays in
place and I have to like quickly put it
down and get my ass on it stays yeah I
hate that thing so much because it's so
thin so the lightest Breeze just [__]
yeah
and your the pressure from your ass
approaching will blow it away yeah yeah
yeah
um and so I I normally don't use it but
yeah but sometimes yeah sometimes a
little extra protection doesn't hurt
yeah you probably love the they have
this thing as well it's pretty common
um where you can clean the toilet seat
if you want to oh with the wet wipes
there's like a there's like a another
spray it's not for your hands
um it's like for you can put some of the
toilet roll and then wipe it yeah yeah
let's do that occasionally yeah it
depends how spicy I'm feeling if it's a
long one I'm like I'm just getting
settled in let's do it okay here's the
question here's the question what do you
do you're desperate for the toilet go in
a public toilet you walk in no toilet
paper and you realize too late
uh uh I've never had that issue you've
never had that issue
or like it's either like there's no
toilet paper or of course I have oh it's
that's what this is why I hate going
into public toilets uh well that's why I
always check before I go in sometimes
you just forget because you're just too
[__] desperate then you that that
first one comes out it's a fat one you
look over you're like oh no Defcon five
it's it's an emergency meeting time guys
hopefully you're with a friend and they
can get help that's like the play right
yeah I mean not your [__] or see
because I've learned from that and so
now in whatever bag I have while I'm out
I always have like pocket tissues just
in case because you never know I think I
have had this I think I've already just
like had a really dirty ass and walked
to the next toilet
because I had no other choice like what
can you do yeah I mean like what like if
you're alone what can you do it's like
it's like when you're at home as well
though right and you realize that
there's no toilets like toilet paper on
the toilet roll you look to where you
usually have all your toilet paper
there's none there either yeah right so
what do you do in that situation at home
uh it's go in the shower yeah you can
shower yeah yeah I just I just like
shower shower that [__] away shower
strap yeah just the good old the good
old [__] shower strap all right
what's your next what's the next tangent
the next tangent is the funniest and
most bizarre Japanese advertisements
I'm surprised we've never talked about
this I saw one the other day right and I
don't know what it was promoting okay
but it was like a cow that was styled
like josuke from JoJo we had like the
pompadour he's like a delinquent and
then the cow walks up to these two
delinquents on the train is like leave
those old people alone and the old
people take a seat and then it cuts to
the product I don't know what they were
I don't know what they were promoting or
what the message was that definitely
sounds like a Japanese ad I have no idea
and then I think it was like some kind
of milk based instant soup it was
something weird right yeah like there's
a lot of weird Japanese ads yeah I mean
like you know I think what's funny is
that like you know in the west there's
that like whole stereotype of like oh
Japanese ads are some of like the most
wackiest that'll make any [__] sense
type of ads and yeah there's certainly a
lot of them but like I think a lot of
people have this weird image that that's
the majority of ads in Japan whereas
there are some normal ads in Japan
volumes are boring they love Chimes
still
they push Jingles so hard one uh one ad
that I recently saw that I thought was
really funny uh was uh you know
obviously because like chainsaw man it's
still massive yeah man uh I saw this
huge like Banner advertisement in one of
the train stations and it was just like
the like 95 of this Banner was just
machima's face
and I've seen this one and I was like
what the [__] is this yeah and I read it
and it's a an ad for a recruitment
company I basically said I want you to
be mine but it was like it was written
in like macular style of like speech and
it's like I want you to be mine come to
this recruitment company I'm like that
is so Giga brain I hate how I effective
I know that ad is yeah you know just by
putting [__] makima's face and being
like you can work under for me yeah you
can be mine you can be mine I'm like
[__] can I have my own makima in my life
man
so sometimes they're like Giga brain
other times it's just like uh you know I
think a lot of the wins ones that I've
seen where it's just like that's kind of
unnecessary is that they take like a
celebrity or a comedian or whatever yeah
they put them into like a weird [__]
like body suit yeah they have a lot of
weird surrealist type of commercials
right yeah what the [__] is happening
yeah like there's this commercial that's
been playing all the time like every
taxi I've gone through recently where
it's these people on stage dancing or
something like that and it's like this
absurdist nightmare where they slowly
turn into puppets or something like that
and then like one person turns into a
puppet but everyone keeps on dancing and
then slowly the entire crew is just like
a [__] is is
a plastic puppet or something like that
and I'm like this is this is the stuff
of nightmares actually what are you
trying to promote here I'm so confident
like taxi ads are like some of my
favorite because it's like they're
clearly trying to like make it you know
interesting and like kind of visually
appealing and like visually like fun
happy times yay but all of the ads are
just like join up with this Cloud
management system for your company they
have that one ad that runs in every
single taxi and it's the translation uh
device oh yeah yeah and then there's
always like these quizzes yeah the taxi
that's like yeah
it'll be like a Japanese phrase and
it'll be like what's the answer in
English and be like it's very nice to
meet you it's lovely to meet you and
it's like I'm like pressing it like
I know this one
I saw this other the other day in a taxi
that was just it was promoting this
mattress right yeah that was meant to be
so stable that uh and how they tried to
promote it was they got someone to jump
on the mattress with like a glass some
red wine
but I noticed in the advertisements
um they had the shot where the sky jumps
on this kind of suit jumps on right I
mean the glass is like and uh like in
front of him in frame right uh but also
in frame was the fact that this glass
was on top of a towel that was opaque
and and you could see the shot where
this guy jumps on the uh jumps on this
mattress he like paddocks for a bit
looks at the glass and then just smiles
and I'm just like you sneaky
[__] how many takes how many
[__] tastes for this girl man
it's basically like this product for the
suite in Japan that's just very long
it's like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they told like a story through like 10
ads where the guy like left his wife and
was gay or something yeah something like
that yeah it was really good oh that was
that was pretty they do a lot of those
actually like SoftBank uh has had this
like long running like story arc in
their advertisements where it's like
they get back uh they get like uh
characters from like Japanese folklore
and like uh put them in situations where
it's like oh you know uh momotaro would
you like uh uh I wanna I wanna way to be
able to contact you when I make it to
the island of the Devils well why not
try SoftBank and it's and this ad series
I guess has been going on for like 10
plus years oh my God and they're still
making it these like recurring
characters so much so I think I went to
a soft bank the other day and I saw that
they were selling much
of these characters make sense why not
why not yeah and I'm like who
who is buying this
yeah SoftBank employees I mean I I also
noticed that a lot of Japanese strategy
when it comes to advertisement is can we
make this thing an anime character have
you have you noticed every time you like
every time I've gone to like a new
prefecture or something oh yeah and they
try to promote whatever that prefecture
is famous for it's like really bad yeah
they're called yudukara yeah but um
every pre-factor or like City or
whatever has this like kind of mascot
type thing usually you know that they
may also make like a giant [__] uh
you know some of them are so [__]
ugly yeah and they're so bad yeah the
designs yeah I like uh
I think it's
the the bear with the the melon and I'm
like it's just a [__] black bear with
a melon on his head this got nothing to
do with Hokkaido yeah I've I've started
to notice because uh I went to yamanashi
prefecture uh like a month ago and then
they had they were trying to size their
wine because of course it did and how
they did that was uh these uh they they
had an a boy Idol group that they had
made to represent all the different
wines that they were that were made
there oh my God and I'm just like really
you had to get like France is crying
right now man [__] it all of Europe is
crying what have you done to our why man
wait so there's like it's like I'm
Chardonnay yeah yeah yeah
and they had made their own [__] like
anime trailer for for these boys as well
and I'm just like oh I need to see this
oh what are you doing wait let me look
it up it's just like yamanashi wine this
is well like outside of Harajuku I don't
know if it's still there for a very long
time uh in front of the exit there was
this like anime manga panel and it
looked like a romance thing but it was
advertising password safety yes you know
yes yes yes
it's like it's like a guy and a girl
texting and they're in love or something
and then it's yeah I can't remember why
but it's literally all just about
securing your passwords and it's like
what the [__] I love Yeah it literally
just if you just take a glance at it it
just looks like a panel from like a
standard Shojo romance manga right when
you look at what they're actually what
if I can find it like yeah can we find
it Abby uh the
um the uh yeah I think I remember one of
them is like the the guys doing like a
cupboard on to like the girl and the
girl's like oh and then the guy's like
do you want to make this relationship as
strong as your password
secure
or something like that I'm just like
that is so Giga brain I love it when
they like yeah I love it when they like
mix mix and match uh mediums and stuff
like that for advertisements
um
well there is an article on Crunchyroll
but it's blocked oh girl like because
we're in Japan yeah I mean right quickly
opening especially Vienna yeah the
headline was said about Shojo manga yeah
promoting I.T safety yeah
uh literally like like this like they're
all
oh oh
okay it's like hey make it's like make
sure to look after your password
oh my God
oh yeah it's like it's like I'll be
waiting until you change your password
that's so hard because somebody asked me
they were like I was with somebody like
what is it what is that advert and I was
like how to put passwords what what do
you mean it's so gigabraine I love it
yeah they get really creative with some
stuff and like really cool ways like the
um that really famous
um 3D curved advertising screen in
Shinjuku oh yeah yeah
jumps out and they've been you know if
you want that's like their equivalent of
Times Square now yeah yeah in Japan it's
like if you want the billboard that's
the one yeah yeah that's curved you do
3D it is pretty sick when one piece red
was out they had like a whole one piece
thing playing on it where Luffy like
jumps out and there's like oh cool
yeah
if we'd be like ah movie jumping on is
screaming he is literally the Tyler one
of anime
hey we should formulate a plan yeah but
uh what always interests me is like
you know sometimes seeing like the Adam
the anime tie-in like products and just
kind of seeing the lengths they will go
to with Evangelion see how they can tie
Aver into this one
very very popular yeah I think the
weirdest ever one I ever saw was I think
they were advertising like horse race
beta uh horse race betting or something
like that and they had made they were
doing boat race spinning as well oh
really yeah because what I saw I saw
like Ava unit one as like a horse like
running it down and like gender was
betting on him I was like this is the
weirdest ass [__] I've ever seen in my
life what I love is the absolute
dichotomir it's like we will not give
the English rights to to make to
licenses to anybody for 20 years oh yes
go ahead make Horseman gamble what the
[__] like we're so strict with what we
give our IP out to unless it's minions
and uh cleaning products and it's like
what the what the [__] why don't you
become super strict about who gets to do
it when it comes to foreign people
exactly like having an English
adaptation like it's just like we don't
want you to ruin the image of Eye of our
IP mean meanwhile here's what we do with
our IP you know it's just it it blows me
[__] so like double-sided like you
see anything like with like uh even like
Nintendo right yeah Nintendo love to be
like we will we are so stringent with
rip if you go to some arcades there are
certain machines that are Mario Party
gambling machines
yeah it's basically a six player Mario
Party gambling machine where it's with
real money you you play and you try and
progress around the board to win more
money yeah it's like I'm sorry what
Nintendo like no guns in games but
gambling is cool yeah just in Japan
it's and you know in terms of like the
image that Japan has in terms of that
advertising I I tell a lot of it is
actually like pretty normal it's not
it's not as crazy as what people think
yeah that's what I'm saying like there's
definitely crazy ones out there but it's
certainly not the majority because I'm
I'm going to say
in Thailand Thailand are actually
[__] amazing and making crazy ass
[__] commercials I've seen some Thai
commercials that I saw on YouTube that
are like more heart-wrenching than some
of like the most heaviest drama films
I've seen in my life there are some Thai
commercials
that are just like a two-minute short
film and then it ends and they're just
like have you heard about life insurance
and I'm just like yo you just [__]
got my heart out for life insurance for
life insurance you're working with the
easiest thing to make yeah but like but
these ads are like these ads are like
like Cheerios gonna make yourself but
these ads are like short films and and
there are like so many tie ads that
don't get uploaded on YouTube that are
just weird as [__] like I remember I'm
having like a flashback of just some of
the adverts I saw as a kid when I was in
Thailand watching on TV and I remember
though I was I was watching I was in
Thailand watching some show and then it
went cut to Commercial and then it
showed the scene of like a group of uh
group of like robbers or like bank heist
people
um and they had like broken into this
building yeah and they're like oh [__] I
think we got the wrong building I don't
think this is the bank and I think and
one guy goes oh I think this is like the
supermarket like there's a fridge over
there
um and so they were like what why why
why why why is that all these like
drinks here have we gotten to the wrong
place and so like we started drinking it
so it's like try it out
and then it zooms out to be like it's a
commercial for an optician to be like
have you do you need a new prescription
for your glasses and it zooms out and
the building they've broken into is a
sperm bank
like American Pie or something and I'm
like that's that was a weird thing to
see as a kid and yeah like go go Google
some Thai commercials because they have
some wild ass [__] but that's the thing
I feel every country has their fair
share of like what the [__] type of
community ads in the UK really yeah in
Australia for instance like there was
one ad that just stuck with me forever
it was it was an ad for a Cadbury
chocolate
um and I think it actually won like uh
like the British one like with the was
it the gorilla the gorilla one yeah that
was huge yeah that was massive yeah
everyone was like I remember when I was
a kid when that came on the TV
everyone's like everyone yeah it's a
gorilla he's playing in the air tonight
honestly that was probably that's not
the biggest the most genius ad I've seen
um yeah there's another one um I don't
know if it's British or Australian it
probably is Australian but there's a one
for uh some kind of Australian beer
um and it's this like it's this couple
that's like sleeping in the bed yeah and
the guy is just sleeping next to his
girl and whatever and his tongue starts
crawling out of his mouth
and it's like like a worm right and and
it goes like across it goes out of the
house and it crawls across the road to
this house party and goes into the
cooler grabs a beer brings it back yeah
and crawls it all the way to the guy's
mouth and then the guy wakes up with the
beer in his mouth and it's like you have
a beer and it's and it's but like at the
time the CG was so good that it was so
incredibly disturbing scene
like out of this guy's mouth and just
crawling around on the ground yeah oh
just [__] like that I think some some
some some adverts I remember they're
like stand out to me we had like the
gorilla one which was like [__] yeah
that was like huge and another one I
think it was uh ad for obviously didn't
do its job because I can't remember the
product it was selling yeah but I
remember the advert itself because it
had that song it was just like
and it looked like a pretentious uh film
about surfers there was this one Surfer
um and you just hear this song in the
background
and then like the uh announcer comes on
and he just goes he waits that's what he
does
the perfect wave tick follows talk
follows tick follows top follows tick
and and it just [__] builds up and he
finds that perfect wave and I don't know
why that advert just like sticks in my
mind so much I'm pretty sure it's a
[__] beer advertisement I want to
watch it it sounds so avant-garde when
you like describe it to me what's up on
God I love uh like anti-drug commercials
as well those are fun oh he's always
like insane
oh yeah oh of course you can forget that
legendary ad the one I think it's I
think it's an Irish ad the one where the
car it's like a drunk driving PSA yeah
the car topples over and hits like 20
kids oh yeah you've seen this one yeah
yeah that one's like whoa yeah who
thought of this one
oh God I Had A Dark Day at the Office
yeah all right I'm feeling like a
tangent okay I feel like a go go for the
tangent
anime tropes we love to hate
it's a guy
it is now High School
how'd you guys do we hate it I hate it
yes I do
I um the moment I see an anime now and
it's like he's a normal high school
like cyberpunk 2077 I nearly clocked out
when he was in school because I was like
do you mean age Runners uh sure yeah
yeah sorry Edge Runners yeah uh when he
was in school I was like I swear to
[__] God if they've made a cyberpunk
and they put it in a [__] school I'm
gonna lose it and then of course he
leaves school that episode yeah thank
God but like I'm just so over anything
with high school I think I've said this
before on the anime yeah yeah board yeah
how okay how do we feel because this is
one of the this is one of the things
that's like parodied the most but like
the over explanations when it comes to
anime fights oh this is
and let's take Jojo and Becky out of
this conversation because I feel like
those are like those are so ridiculous I
need the explanation yes of course I I
need them so like you're talking about
like say like in a in a Sports Anime for
example where like as as you know this
like second by second play is happening
some guy in the [__] crowd has an ex
has time to do a three minute
explanation
or even like any Shonen battle anime
yeah
would you like the hunter narration
though I don't know something about it
it's gone realized he [__] up
I don't I don't know I I think it's just
like so commonplace now where I just
don't think about it anymore I do think
it's
kinda lazy I feel like if you're if you
make it interesting you can convey all
this information without needing to tell
the audience right so don't tell right
yeah yeah because because I I was
thinking about this because I think it's
just something we've accepted that anime
just [__] does you know this is this
is just a thing we're gonna explain
what's happening
um and it's not only until like recently
when we've just seen examples where it's
been handled better than it has in the
past like I think uh I think Jujutsu
Kyson has had a really good balance
between showing what's happening versus
like explaining what's happening
um and I recently did like a video on
like manga adaptations and I realized
I I've realized what difference it makes
when you just take out the explanation
uh take out the explaining and just show
what's happening on screen and it's just
like holy [__] this works so much better
it just takes so much more effort yeah
but so few anime actually go out and do
it yeah and that's the problem right is
that like some of the best stories in
Manga and Anime uh you know don't
require a whole lot of explanation or
even dialogue to like tell you what's
happening like you know like blam for
example right like that blogger has
barely any dialogue at all but it's
still coherent enough because it shows
you every step of the way visually and
as long as you can like kind of put the
pieces together as to like the sequence
of what's Happening then it's [__]
epic but the problem is as you said it
just takes more brain power to figure
out what's happening because it's very
much open to interpretation right so I
think they've just like yeah maybe it is
laziness I don't know maybe they maybe
the authors just have decided being like
well I could show them but at the same
time I'm afraid to alienate any readers
into what exactly is happening and it
might you know deter them from enjoying
the rest of the story it comes from
manga right so I think it's that's why
we often get this over explanation kind
of approach to it because because you
need it yeah
there's so many
so many manga that have shown in manga
that I really struggle to see what's
going on in the fight yeah like I don't
know am I the only person who has this
problem no there are some fights where
I'm just like I don't know what the
[__] happening there are some manga
that are better than others um sometimes
I just I I I am looking at the Battle
and I am I'm really reading the panels
like going over it four times and I'm
like I still in my head cannot figure
out what you you read Claymore didn't
you yeah I read all of Claymore that was
hard holy [__] because I I
um I've like I've reread it like
recently
um and that was almost [__]
impossible to discern what's happening
later fights yeah because it's like
weird in group fights you have like all
of these Claymore where all of them are
like silver heads uh silver head women
wearing the same [__] uniform and I'm
like who is even fighting right now I
jet I actually cannot tell who's
Swinging The Sword yeah it's just it's
that that one was like but I think
that's the thing right it's like it's
it's it's all up to the the different
author on like their skill on being able
to like show the flow of movement right
like the reason why I like berserk for
example like Mira did such a good job on
that is that like a lot of the fights
don't really have an explanation right
and if and if there is an explanation
it's maybe like one or two frames right
yeah but he was such he was such a
master the joke was really easy to find
because he was such a master at like
figuring out the flow of movement and
like where to show it and how to show it
that it was just very self-explanatory
even in like big fights right Claymore
was hard to follow yeah yeah even though
the Claymore has amazing [__] art
like the monster designing Claymore was
like incredible yeah uh but the way the
story went because of the story because
of how the story was structured around a
group of people who basically are look
exactly the same and uh or dress exactly
the same yeah and have the same kind of
weapons just
I really like that yeah cool yeah it was
a really cool it was a really cool world
check it out if you haven't yeah it was
quite good but stopped don't don't the
anime had a original ending remember
when anime had like remember when the
anime just went its own part I think it
was gonna like and was like I'm gonna do
my own thing I'm gonna end it myself
anyway is the part up until like that's
the first halfway point yeah yeah yeah
um because there's no High School in it
so that's why what do you hate about
Heist is there a single anime that's
based in high school that is like I can
forgive this yeah like I I mean okay
there are a lot of shows where it makes
a lot of sense and I I've got on this
rant before and there's a lot of shows
where I just feel like if anything it
detracts from it
um like obviously
um like you know uh light being a high a
college student or a high school student
as well I have no qualms about that they
make sense in the story it uh you know
adds to the reason why you'd never
suspect this character to be doing this
stuff this is a normal high school
student but there's other ones where I'm
just like like Tokyo Revengers did do
they really need to be high school
students like straight up like that show
is actually they were Middle School
students was like I I went on this whole
land when we talked about this before
but Tokyo Avengers I was actually ruined
for me because they are all middle
schools yeah it's like it makes the show
so much [__] I don't understand why
they did that but it's such an
interesting dichotomy isn't it because
we say that about Tokyo Avengers and yet
we're okay with hanayama from Baki being
14.
is it it's such a weird life to watch
back they're all high school students
but like it's like not even the heat the
main characters high school student
fighting like fully grown men yeah yeah
it's literally nothing in back he makes
any sense so it doesn't matter he's
literally never in school no he's a high
school student he was he's the worst
high school student in Japan he's never
how is that man not expelled I don't
like it he is never at school where are
the police I guess they but do you think
the police are going to stop him [__]
U.S military at one point I don't think
it's an issue I'm sorry if there's a
high if if if in this world the U.S
military comes and talks to a high
school student about like asking him to
not fight because he's basically a
weapon of mass destruction I think all
other normal rules go out the window
um unless and your dad just talked to
Obama the other day we discussed this I
think the series that like I think the
series that Jarred me the most in terms
of like adding High School in it
um is this is a pretty old one actually
it's a awari no Seraph
um yeah yeah do you remember this so
like I really like this show but I like
the show as well no but but like I said
like I remember the first like two or
three episodes we we introduced to this
like post-apocalyptic world where
vampires are taken over and there's only
like sex of humanity yeah and it's like
it's a [__] amazing world this the
main character wakes up and he's like
wait he finds out that he's just like
food for the vampires he has to escape
and all this and you're like damn this
world's metal he escapes finds like the
freedom Squad the revolutionaries the
loss remaining humans
and then there's a [__] high school
Arc and I'm just like you're in a
post-apocalyptic World [__] you
have tried really [__] hard you have
to try really [__] hard to completely
forgot about it yeah dude to like bring
High School into this but you've managed
it somehow and I don't know why you
thought this was a good idea and it's so
weird because later on they pretty much
just drop that all anyway so I don't
under like that okay that was a show
that I think that really like plagued it
like because it was when it first came
out it was like really um especially the
anime like people were freaking out
about it yeah it just dropped after
Attack on Titan had a similar kind of
edginess to it if I were looking for I
think it just yeah the high school kind
of element ruined it yeah it's like it's
like the equivalent of if like halfway
through season one of Attack on Titan
they just like go back to school yeah
just realized it was like let's just
[__] make these children grow up yeah
they should actually have like a good
[__] dollar
oh yeah it's yeah it's I you know I
would I would like for more stories to
be set outside of high school and I
think with slowly starting to see that I
don't know or at least or at least like
if it's going to be in a high school get
it to the point where you know we get to
see them once they're out of school or
something you know like or once they're
like you know like B stars did a really
good job of that where like it starts
off in a school but then the second half
he's not in the school anymore and he's
like out in the real world and like that
I think like balance is cool I don't
mind that a lot of people always argue
they're like it's more relatable to the
the target audience yes and I'd say what
aspect of jotaro do I relate to because
him being a 17 year old kid as a high
school student I mean like I feel this
argument of it being more targeted is
like there's a reason why Jose is the
only JoJo that was in a high school yeah
right right like even even [__] uh
Jose uh even Joe Tara right like even
though he's a high school student you
never see him in the first right like I
find that they spent a lot of shows
where they have a high school
protagonist often spend no time in high
school anyway so what's the point of
even bringing this up just and and
sometimes
I I find that kids aren't that [__]
dumb I feel like people think kids are
so much more stupid than they are that
if it's just not the same if they're not
in the exact same situation they can't
relate or have some kind of tie to it
and it's like yes obviously when I was
in school and Harry Potter was going on
that was something I could relate to a
lot more and that was a banger but yeah
it wasn't like I didn't want to watch 24
and Jack Bauer go around shooting people
you know what I mean like I yeah I find
that kids want those other stories
anyway so stop saying that the only
reason is because they're targeting high
school students well it's it's fine that
they don't they're not that dumb in the
case with Japan it's it goes both ways
it's it's the fact that yes they're
trying to Target high school students
who are currently in high school where
it's like oh this character I like is
also in high school I relate but it's
also targeted towards younger adults who
have just come out of high school as
well where because to a lot of Japanese
people this idea of like in high school
and being a student was kind of like a
golden age right otherwise which is a
really sad but it's but it's the true
which is which is weird right because
it's this I'm pretty sure I've talked
about it before but it's like yeah it's
this weird like difference in between
the west and Japan of like in Japan high
school is like a time where it's like I
wish I was back there and then in the
west high schools movies and stuff like
that are always like look how [__] high
school was can you relate guys being an
adult is so much better yeah and it's
just this like weird dichotomy so it's
like I get that sometimes they want to
do it for that purpose but I also do
agree that a lot of the times they just
throw it into a [__] high school
because like oh that's an easy setting I
don't have to come up with like an
original concept for a setting or a
world yeah and then minus double points
if it's in a school and then there's
unnecessary lewdness all the time or fan
service but they're just like groping
each other and you're like what I mean
that's literally everything I know yeah
I mean most of that most of that has
been transferred over to the fantasy
genre now I think yeah mostly for sure I
think High School edgy has uh I don't
know if it's good
it's your fantasy world and a lot of
like medieval stories and they had
slaves in them but also it's a fantasy
world it's a it's it's what you're only
limited by what your mind can imagine
and why does everyone imagine slavery in
their world
what's going on like why are we trying
to bring this back
it's just you know
we knew Easter guys the way I watched
now it's just like oh there's the
rescuing the slave walk is he just go is
he's going to free the slave this time
or is he going to take the slave under
his own arms
the slave is falling in love with it
he's a savings
I mean I'm white so I don't want to talk
too much
but a lot of the time she feels like
well we got this character who's kind of
just cool how do we kind of make him
more likeable yeah
just give just give him a savior complex
speaking which is another tangent I want
to go on uh the most I the most iconic
scenes involving bathrooms and toilets
in movies and TV shows
[Music]
the most iconic scenes involving
bathrooms and toilets in movies and TV
shows the only one I can think of is uh
in [__] Trainspotting when he dies
into the toilet to get the drugs oh yeah
other than that
um oh and uh something about Mary no no
I don't think I've seen that movie have
you not seen that movie with a come yes
he like Jack explained he jacks off into
the mirror before the date right or he's
jacking off before there's something
about Mario is that something else
something about Mary I'm pretty sure
right because it's still all right yeah
it is
um it's got uh Cameron Diaz yeah yeah
that's something about Mary right is it
can you can you Google this make sure um
okay this so so there's two there's two
yeah yeah so there's that and then
there's the scene which I think like
explain the first scene all I hear so I
think
yeah he's having a date and he wants to
you know because he might be getting so
he wants to jack off before he goes out
so you know maybe that's a lot yeah yeah
and he comes and he doesn't know where
the [__] went
yeah and then it turns out it was on it
was behind his ear yeah
it's Cameron Diaz at the door and she's
like oh you have some gel I'll take that
and she takes it for some reason and
puts it and puts in her hair yeah and um
yeah
is it actually possible to be good hair
gel breaking it down but no no the scene
I was thinking of I don't know if this
is still there's something about marry
them it might be something else but uh
it's the zipper scene
where I can't remember this one I think
I think it is Ben Stiller he's a
he's uh pissing in the toilet yeah and
then he just kind of like he's just
staring out the window right and he's
just kind of like like having like a
thousand yards today or whatever and
then he realizes he's staring at the
window of a girl getting changed or
something like that right and so he
starts to panic and then he zips up
[Music]
I'm pretty sure it's Ben Stiller
um so basically he's he Zips you've seen
this scene to me and I feel like it's
Steve Carell in my mind I don't know why
like why am I picturing 40 year old
maybe this is Steve curl scene as well
maybe there's a Steve Carell scene but
he's remade it yeah yeah but it's
hanging homage yeah but it's iconic
because even just describing that every
every man in the world basically you
hear him zip up every man in the world
winces he zips up and he screams and
then and then there's this
oh God it's a [__] iconic scene
there's a scene where he uh he asks for
help and basically every guy who's just
like okay let me let me help you they
look at what they look at what has like
what he's what he's got himself into
yeah and they're just like yo what the
[__] man what the [__] and the most
[__] up thing is there's a shot while
they actually show what has happened oh
there's a shot where the zipper is
entangled with the skin and it's just
like for a second how do you just are
you that is that is now like become a
core memory that has become a core
memory in my mind oh my boss and
everyone and everyone who's watched that
film oh I'm gonna google iconic bathroom
scenes because now I'm the only one the
only other one I can think of is uh I
forgot which Austin Powers film it is uh
but there's that scene where he's inside
the the lair of uh Dr Evil yeah and he
like runs into the bathroom and uh and
and as he's taking this like extremely
long piss the two two henchmen are
talking like some like secret you know
talks or whatever but he can't hear him
because the piss is so loud so he stops
to listen and the henchmen just like
we'll get him really suddenly and he
just starts pissing he's like and he
just does that on and off for like five
minutes that's the only other one I can
think of Home Alone one where he's
getting changed and then he slaps his
face and goes ah with the Aftershock
what was that in Home Alone when he he's
you know getting ready and then he
applies the aftershave to his like bare
skin yeah and screams because obviously
it burns yeah he's not a man yet I had
my my leg up and all the blood's rushing
back in my life
I did find the scene you're talking
about uh it's from uh Along Came Polly
right oh yeah I'm getting those two
mixed up and still in Jennifer Aniston
okay okay yeah okay Ben Stiller an
iconic bathroom scenes man what can you
say so there's The Shining technically
in the bathroom oh yeah it is Johnny
[Applause]
I actually heard a really fun uh well
like I guess little factoid about that
is that like the actress uh I've
forgotten her name but you know how
she's like [__] terrified and
screaming that was apparently a genuine
reaction because she didn't know that
they were actually gonna get a real ax
and actually go through the door so
she's actually freaking out well Kubrick
was a [__] madman yeah okay [__]
yeah okay he wasn't asked he made
amazing [__] movies but hearing some
of hearing about some of the uh hearing
about some of the stories that happened
on set on in everyone in his films he is
I would hate to work there was also
there was also that scene in The Shining
that I think apparently took 127 takes
yeah he's crazy yeah and they made them
redo it just so they can get mentally
fatigued and actually [__] just crazy
yeah because of how many times he asked
them to redo the take what an [__]
and uh in the Clockwork Orange where
they had the scene where they uh propped
up the yard oh yeah he actually
scratched his corner or something like
yeah and so when he's screaming stop
stop he was actually screaming because
yeah
scratched his Claudia and he was like
screaming in pain and Kubrick's like
keep rolling keep rolling this is great
this is a good take this good film this
is something I mean back back way back
when movies just were starting and
becoming a big thing and a lot of money
was being put put into him like a lot of
people just died during filming stuff
yeah Big scenes like Coliseum scenes or
yeah there's a Noah's Ark
film which a bunch of people died well
there's that famous one of like uh you
know the never-ending story uh no uh
there's like this fantasy film The
Neverending Story like really famous in
the US but uh there's this scene where
like the the kid is like pulling a horse
or a swamp yeah and the horse like
slowly starts to like sink apparently
that horse actually died way back in
animals and movies they did not give up
straight up died in that scene and they
cut it right before the horse actually
like drowned and died and I'm just like
what the [__] that is depressing yeah
it's super depressing yeah the only
other thing I can think of is
um that's it there was a Texas Chainsaw
Massacre where there's a scene where the
last one I think it's the first one
there's a scene where because the
because it was so hot where they were
filming and uh the main murderer had to
wear like the mask during filming and it
was [__] he was getting like heat
stroke and he accidentally like there's
a scene where he cuts like one of the uh
one of the girl's finger yeah and he
actually cut the finger and she was
screaming in real pain
he was so delirious that he like didn't
know that he was actually cutting like a
real finger
just like the [__] you can get away with
like back then God someone someone's
getting a lawsuit nowaday man
I'm looking at more iconic bathrooms
yeah what's the more iconic bathroom
scenes but put iconic [__] scenes
[Music]
I mean there's the I mean again going
back to Austin Powers with the Fat
Bastard you know like sitting on the
toilet he's like but I didn't have any
calls I've got so many iconic bathroom
scenes thinking about like that first
scene when he wakes up and he's like
dethawed and he spends like ages on the
urinal and he's just like that's because
Austin Powers is like the epitome of
like pee pee poo poo joke yes in film
it's like that's that's why we love it
um I'm actually willing to check gbt
like 10 iconic proofing scenes yeah well
there's a woman where they have the
laxatives he drinks like stuff he
started shooting oh there's also that
scene in White Chicks as well where he
has the cheese accidentally yeah
I love that scene
um God White Chicks is a film that would
not fly today no I'm just thinking about
it that would be a film that would be
canceled so fast I think Tropic Thunder
could be made nowadays no American Pie
there's like so many there's one where
he's like shaving his pubes yeah for
some reason throws the pubes out the
window they get blown into like uh and
uh one of the wedding venues oh my God
every other scene in American Pie yeah
is like half what happened to toilet
humor I remember when every other like
comedy film had toilet humor in it and
and now we're just like oh we're better
than that
I don't think we are because I still
love that line in uh in American Pie
where it's like I went to band camp and
I played a trumpet with my [__] like
it's it's the dumbest line but it's
stuck with me for all these years oh
yeah any nuts in the sunscreen yeah
that's gross I love those movies man
what is the next AI generated prompt
guards let me know
the weirdest food combinations people
would actually enjoy roast sandwiches
sandwiches
sandwiches it's kind of similar to the
last thing I guess but uh food
combination we have in there of
curiosity we only have one more after
this actually weird food combinations
um mayo and anything it's pretty huge
Japanese Mayo Japanese Mayo just give me
Japanese mayo man keep your mouth you
could just put that with anything the
more I like Mayo I don't know why
as a kid I remember heating mayonnaise I
used to think it was disgusting it
looked it looked vile as well well but
but I mean UK Mayo is yeah I mean
Western Mayo is like different yeah we
have like the widest shade of white mayo
and it's like isn't it like a little bit
more watery as well yeah yeah I never
liked that yeah that was gross [__]
[__] yeah Japanese Mayo all the way this
is creamy what about adding cheese
to what what does cheese not work with
huh let them cook whatever audience
suggestions
because because I I asked this because
growing up okay well there was a big
separation for me between like let's say
Western food and Asian Cuisine and the
concept of like adding cheese to like a
lot of like Thai Cuisine and like Asian
Cuisine I was just like I don't see it
happening yeah but then but then I
discovered Korean cuisine that does that
I'm like oh maybe this can work maybe
maybe we need to like maybe we need to
think about this a bit more yeah you
know because like Sam was like she's
like a crutch for food I think because
like not not for at least for foods that
are bad can be made
more edible with cheese on them because
cheese is so good and overpowering
anything else it's right right and I
find that normally it's at least in in
Japan and stuff the cheaper the food the
more chance that we choose involved yeah
that's just because they're like all
right let's let's put some cheese to
mask this it'll be like I don't know
what will they have cheese with on here
a lot of the time like Asian food I
don't really want cheese with it okay
how do we feel about cheese and rice
that's a little scary okay what can you
give me an example of food like just a
bit of rice or some [__] cheese
honestly I've never tried it but I've
tried it it could be good I mean because
I mean mayo and rice is nice so
that mayor and cheese are not the same
things yeah but what I'm saying yeah
because because I I was just like cheese
and rice that wouldn't that would never
work no it does work yeah then and then
I there I tried a few in a few places in
Japan I'm like okay this this is like
it's like it's like the pastor of Asia
cheese and carbs right
carbs and cheese go like hand in hand
yeah yeah I don't [__] with people when
they put like nacho cheese on like
broccoli or something I've had that a
few times in Japan you gotta be like
cheese broccoli and then I order it and
it's like nacho cheese like the canned
nachos
[__] does that go well with you know I
would argue nothing I will accept it
with oh really I put mayonnaise on it uh
wait sorry no no we're talking about
nachos
that's not food I'm like that that
barely goes with nachos give me real
cheese with nachos yeah give me real
cheese is there any point where I would
choose that [__] fake cheese over the
grilled cheese what I'm trying to think
is there anything cheese doesn't go well
with is cheese just the hacked I was
gonna say cake but we literally have
cheesecake we literally have cheesecake
[__] uh his cheese just that Opie no
cheese is very open I'm just like
thinking that it's just fat and carbs so
yeah that's the stuff it makes it way
more unhealthy this is like some dish or
like food item where if you put it with
cheese it becomes immediately disgusting
well dude I don't know because you can
get like brata and some fruit you're
right yeah and you get like fondue as
well yes you dip like you dip like this
I think it's cheese is so versatile
generally like there's there's so many
different flavors you can have with it
yeah I think there's a there's a cheese
for everything unfortunately
unfortunately I think there is I think
there's a cheese factory okay this is
cheesy quality this is one this is one
thing I don't get where I've been to
like some let's say high-class
restaurants right okay and they have a
cheese course which comes after the main
course and I think the French do this a
lot uh whether you have cheese is like a
dessert yeah I didn't get that I I do
not get that get it because normally
you're just drinking at that point right
so it's more of like a snacking thing
and it's not like a very heavy
um sweet like taste it's like you can
have a little bite savoriness but it is
a lot
I don't know how people can handle it by
the time I finished the main course I'm
like I'm [__] done and they're like
oh we have another cheese course and I'm
like what you want me to eat Savory
stuff after this I'm
fine man I'm
I'm I barely get the dessert after a
course anyway because I'm as you said
like I want to be full with the main
course right so I don't have space for
anything else but like sometimes I've
been tempted to be like yeah I'll take a
little nibble some cheese
but the problem is is that a lot of
those like cheese boards is like it's
like six or seven pieces of different
cheese so it's just like that's just
like I was expecting maybe two you know
yeah it's just too much what else
shouldn't work
good that sweet sweet and savory can
work but it's it's hard to do it's it's
hard to do I think okay I'm not a fan of
like red bean things being like like
kidney beans no no like the red bean
dessert recipes yeah they have alcohol
and they try and make it like they add
it to stuff and I'm like no
like what like like ice cream and stuff
yeah ice cream it's like are you a fan
of the red bean paste to begin with
sometimes I've had it it's pretty good
but I'm rarely like super hyped about it
because I feel like it's just because
Japan just didn't have sugar for a long
time so they were like let's just use
this
like just admit it Japan like you didn't
have sugar and this is what you'd make
this is your dessert yeah but I mean
it's good
I'm convinced they have a bean Surplus
and they're trying to get rid of it oh
yeah of course that's why we figured out
70 million ways to use the soybean yeah
that's that's true actually they put soy
with everything yeah soybeans we've
literally figured out every combination
possible to use on a soybean you put it
in the garbage for a week you're like oh
[__] I can't you wait a minute
oh okay yeah okay
there's got to be some stuff I'm not a
fan of red bean paste either I don't
know I don't know if you have to like
grow up with it do you think we like
chocolate so much because we grew up
with it or is it just actually that Opie
[Music]
I like chocolate with fruit it's good
fruit is good one thing I've not like
chocolate covered strawberries and stuff
uh yeah it makes strawberries a lot
better yeah hell yeah oranges
I mean if he can make you like oranges
that's uh the only way that orange is
edible yeah there's actually one thing I
don't like which a lot of people do like
um salted chocolate never been a fan
really I don't know yeah never been a
fan same thing with chocolate with chili
chocolate as well I don't like chili
chocolate chili chocolate I don't I
don't understand I don't get chili
chocolate why people do that no uh I'm
Thai I love
spicy chitty stuff yeah get that [__]
out of my desserts I've never understood
chili chocolate yeah what are you gonna
say corner I like chili chocolate what
what do you like about it because what I
don't like about it is the fact that
it's like I like you know I like some
spice in my food and I like sweetness
but like spice and sweetness is couldn't
be further from the opposite in terms of
pallets like a almost like a forbidden
like I think that's what makes you kind
of nice it's a little bit forbidden
would you say it's a little bit
deviously
feeling a little bit naughty
combine these two flavors
I have the same opinion about chili
chocolate as whenever I see a shot and I
look at like the ingredients of the
shots and it has Tabasco sauce in it and
I'm like oh yeah and I'm just like oh
[__] get Get Bloody Mary's away from you
I do not understand Bloody Mary's ass
dude I went out last night and they
ordered a bloody mary the person I was
with and this look at this [__] thing
let me show you I'll try and show the
camera too you know what's kind of weird
I I've never really liked a bloody mary
but for some reason oh my God same with
a whole stick of celery whole stick of
celery that's that's not the wildest
[__] I've seen I mean you freaking can't
see this but I mean yeah that Ash just
came with it
Australians really like Bloody Marys and
I don't know why it's because it's a
drink of Alcoholics all of my yeah it is
how alcoholic it's like the smoothie for
alcohol it's The Hangover alcoholic
drink you know I'm detoxing I'll have a
tomato drink this time I I don't get it
because it's you're just eating a meal
you know it feels it feels like a meal
and uh like the wildest [__] is the uh I
got one after after I get it the one
[__] I've seen is like the Bloody Marys
and whisk in Wisconsin which I think is
like more unhealthy than most meals uh
because I I swear to go like we went to
this bar and Sydney Sydney's mum uh
Sydney's mom and Sydney loves Bloody
Mary's but only from Wisconsin and I
remember I go into this bar and they
order a bloody Mary and I'm used to like
Bloody Marys having some witch and then
like a celery or something
um I swear to God this wasn't like a
cocktail it was it was just they took
like a meal and they'd like processed it
put this put it in this drink and then
out of this drink they had a burger
on a stick and some wings that they that
they had put in this drink and served it
I [__] you not what the [__] okay they
put a burger on a stick and then stuck
it in the Bloody Mary and I'm like this
this is too far this has gone too far
how much is that Bloody Mary is it like
20 bucks yeah I think about 15 20 bucks
to at the bars in Wisconsin they will do
anything they can to not eat their
vegetables
not to mock Americans again I'm sorry
but like a lot of the time they'll have
something healthy or the guys have
healthy and they'll just find 10 other
ways to make it unhealthy yeah
um I don't like honey on pizza
I'm not a fan I like honey on cheese
pizza I don't agree I think it's
Abomination see I I didn't I'm of the
same opinion as a pineapple and pizza
yes get sweet stuff off of them yeah I
agree pineapple and pizza too is the
ultimate does not work combo okay to
stop trying to make it what about
pineapple in a burger
I'm still not I don't know why you can
how I can do all they want I'm not I'm
not bad I'm I'm not sold but it's not as
bad as pineapple and pizza for me what
about like sweet and sour pork that has
pineapple in it this way it's sour pork
is pineapple right the pork should be
the sweet and sour right I don't even
know I don't need a pineapple to do it
like I don't want that I don't want that
watery bite that the pineapple gives and
I know they fry it sometimes yeah but at
that point I'm like why are we even
using the pineapple let me just find
something else it's like putting oranges
in my salad you know I hate oranges
inside I know you I know you hate it
because you hate oranges I [__] love
oranges but just get that [__] out of my
salad yeah any fruit in my salad you
don't like apples in my salad [__] this
is like that's so much one percent thing
I've ever said
um yeah but yeah I that's yeah some
combination is not a fan of yeah yeah
all right all right let's look at the
last AI generated tangent what is it the
most ridiculous anime hairstyles and
what that says about the character
[Laughter]
I mean uh Yu-Gi-Oh yeah I think yeah
every every character from you every
character in you just like Chloe just
like well not even not even Joe just
like just Yugi like like first of all I
feel bad for cosplayers because they
first they have to figure out what the
[__] is going on with you he's here and
second of all I'm just imagining like
does he style that [__] every morning
like how long must that take I think you
says commitment commitment it is
I think Yu-Gi-Oh has ruined every card
game anime character design because
sometimes you just look at a card game
like anime character and you're like
this is a rip-off Yu-gi-oh character
yeah you can always tell when an anime
is about card games when they have the
craziest craziest ass [__] hair that
would not exist in real life even by
anime standards man it begins with Hugo
it's not even the hair either it's just
like just character designs in general
like all harsh edges all very like
pointy yeah all different colors it
can't just be one color like multiple
colors they have to have like streaks or
some [__] getting more sick though
because it was like the only only thing
that was caution is always rounded soft
and colorful and here was this show that
was [__] crazy and every character
had the most absurd hair and you're just
like what the [__] yeah yeah because I
remember even like the most normal
character hairstyle wise in Yu-Gi-Oh is
probably maybe like I don't know Pegasus
right but even then it's like his
[__] character design is so [__]
whacked out and he's so batshit insane
as a personality where it's like he
plays love a pretty normal hairstyle
honestly it's just it's just very very
long and you know straight and white but
like you know but everything else about
him is just like whoa all right chill
what does the hairstyle say about the
characters though that's what I'm in
true they're the main character
the amount of times you're sitting in a
classroom when you're like I spot the
main character I can tell who the main
character is let me let me let me just
look around and see who has the craziest
ass [__] ass it's just it's just a
matter of like I think so many
characters so many like series that have
so many characters especially they're
the only way you can differentiate is
being like what color have we used on
the color wheel yet let's make it that
color is there any anime where the
character changes their hairstyle
um
I'm sure there is uh yeah Dragon Ball Z
shut the [__] up Joey actually you know
how bro
skoku
Goku is dude it's like a completely
different character who the [__] is this
yeah Goku literally has a lion mane yeah
that's super saiyan 3. do you know do
you know what's ruin Super Saiyan 3 for
me yeah he has no eyebrows and once I
noticed that I could have not noticed
that oh my God he doesn't they replace
his eyebrows with muscles his eyebrows
just like go up into his hair like look
at Super Saiyan 3 Goku and they have
replaced his eyebrows with muscles and
once I've noticed that I cannot not
notice that it's probably just always
just Tori I'm being like man I'm
spending too much time on the hair I
just forgot the eyebrows so I guess I'm
still using some of these characters
I've never seen there's a gravel dare
bloice from gosic has this insane like
torpedo hair oh yes yeah I love him he's
[__] sick and then obviously Charles
zebra Tanya that's not like a bit that's
his actual hair
like an accessory that's his hair oh my
God so he's not wearing a wig like a
judge yeah yeah and uh I guess uh Ken
Patchy from Bleach yeah yeah a lot of
Bleach characters have some wild hair
yeah
from ping pong the animation I don't
even know this character I forgot about
that man um uh oh yeah oh yeah tender
from Romer half as well he's got he's
all crazy it's ragio from kill the kill
as well she's literally just rainbows in
her hair at some point oh bro I forgot
about her yeah kill every character in
cheeky
uh yeah JoJo's weird because JoJo's hair
is just half hat half hat yeah like it's
like a weird that he's the hat is the
head the Hat doesn't do anything in his
hair uh it's very odd uh there's also
obviously
um Death the Kid from oh yeah oh yeah
yeah
that's good that that actually does tell
us a little bit about the character yeah
yeah that he loves symmetry except it's
not symmetry except it's not something
it's the one thing that's not
symmetrical yeah I I love it when it
whenever whenever you want to make a
character see more mature just flatten
their hair like get the spikes out
flatten the hair they are an adult now
that's what you did
honestly in real life as well calm down
settle down go to life
yeah damn or just have them like grow
their hair out and if they're if they're
if they're meant to be the good looking
main character they'll have their eyes
slightly covered and it'll be like oh
yeah yeah there's always the there's
always the streak here if they're a
little bit of the quirky character give
them the uh-huge yeah if they're a
happy-go-lucky character they'll have
like the quiff
s I'm ready for anything
character that just runs into everything
why why is it we're going back to tropes
now but why is it the Trope whenever you
want to make an anime character look
sassy just get just give them like the
the [__] slit eyes man you know the
eyes that never open and I'm just like
what well because it makes you be like
what are you actually looking at what
are you hiding what are you hiding
why are you opening those eyes man
what's that [__] I think you guys thank
God you guys are saying that if I said
that that's so racist these Asian people
opening their eyes what's happening with
them yeah I'm just I look at Brock and
I'm like
what is wrong
what do you want to [__] uh TSA and
immigration like what are you up to but
then but then the opposite can be said
right of like when you do it finally see
his eyes you're like oh [__] [__]
when they open their eyes you're like oh
[__] it's going down that's when they
reveal their grand plan they read in
business when you can see their pupils
yeah
[Music]
what's a hairstyle that you looked at in
an anime and you're like that could
probably work in real life as ridiculous
as Sasuke because I did it yeah that's
true yeah
like I could as as weird as it is I
could imagine someone pulling off like a
Death the Kid haircut
uh because it's like it's just yeah I
think they have you know it's just like
white streaks here right that go around
like it will look weird as [__] but it's
probably the most realistic I don't
think the half hair colors look pretty
cool in real life actually oh like the
the half off yeah
I've seen people do that
um what uh what colors do you think what
anime colors you think work in real life
definitely not pink like the ones that
happen in anime that dude
you know what you know what doesn't work
ever blue like light blue like it never
I'm like green green looks like ass in
real life in calling out Jacksepticeye
and cranking Place
good they could take it the big boys
what do you think Jack stop doing it
because it got lazy yeah that too yeah
there's a lot of it's a lot of
management does anyone do it aside from
streamers and YouTube yeah
I don't even want to know how much how
much die ninja head to use it just
doesn't look good in real life yeah does
orange look good [__] no because I'm
just thinking about Ichigo and I'm like
damn Ichigo got drip but I'm like
Giorgio does don't know Ginger no Ginger
though okay okay yeah Ginger Ginger
looks fine but like this gingers you
look Ginger looks great but like if
you're Japanese then it's a different
story oh yeah it does very I think Gigi
hair on a Japanese person is a little
like whoa you know yeah yeah I guess it
does depend on uh skin complex exactly
exactly yeah I I'm sticking to my hair
color I want to see someone pull off
gone's haircut from Hunter Hunter when
he's like an adult
there's someone's done it online have
they yeah someone's done it I've seen
someone do I've seen someone do it oh my
God I've seen like somebody do it it's
really [__] sick it was like yeah
okay now I want to see someone pull off
the Homer Simpson haircut that's what I
want to see in real life I'm getting
that yeah
I want to see that in real life to be
like all right it looks it looks fine on
Homer but how does it look on an actual
person
Wild on a racial person
oh my God I wanna like I feel like one
like
one studio just always does character
designs well including the haircuts and
everything Studio trigger I don't know
why yeah something about Studio trigger
character designs they always [__]
stand out every single time and
sometimes it only takes like one [__]
streak of color and you're like okay
that's Riku from kill or kill I know now
yeah her Style's great yeah it does it
does reflect her energy as well yeah
yeah they're really good at getting the
hairstyles that reflect the characters
very well yeah like it's slick and cool
the character won't be slick literally
everyone from like cyberpunk Edge
Runners as well yeah like everyone looks
so distinct oh but just like Lucy's hair
and [__] inside man I remember first
time seeing Lucy's character designed
her hair her like everything I'm like
damn I was like trigger still got it man
it's trigger still I just played that
boy scenes like Perfection
perfect that's why he's the ghost why is
the ghost
I love that [__] it's so good I [__]
love
using certain react Clips uh to rate
like you know doing anything yeah and
it's the same thing it's the Charlie
scream isn't that one is yeah yeah the
Charlie screams oh yeah anyway that was
the final tangent we went on yeah uh
hopefully you guys enjoyed this AI
generated episode
um I was impressed with the topics yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah some of them we know
ourselves some of them were uh very on
brand for trash taste and and it brought
up a bunch of topics I'm surprised we it
took us this long to actually cook about
yeah yeah yeah very impressed yeah very
important we might do this again did you
enjoy which would you like to see
another AI generated episode trash taste
being slowly overtaken by uh AI
overlords let us know in the comments
I don't know this just felt like a
normal trash taste episode for me but
hey look at these patrons that's so
beautiful they're not AI generated
hopefully hopefully fingers crossed we
didn't generate the muscle
trash taste is fully funded by ourselves
but hey if you like to support the show
make sure to go over to our patreon
patreon.com
Twitter send us memes on the subreddit
and if you hate our face listen to us on
Spotify
but yeah guys oh yeah that's been this
episode of trash taste we'll see you all
wait no oh do you want to do a trash
taste AI generator AI generated I want a
general AI generated
all right let me log in real quick again
like just just to quickly touch upon it
absolutely terrifying how well I
generated [__] is getting uh yeah I mean
we've made this because of the last
episode where we talked about AI yeah
let's let's give it let's give it yeah
give it a test uh it's very scarily
accurate it's worked out pretty [__]
well very good very good topic say all
right thank you all right give us the
outro Connor well folks that's all for
this episode of our podcast thanks for
tuning in and we hope you didn't find it
too painful we'll be back next week with
more unfunny content for your enjoyment
until then stay safe and keep laughing
or not keep laughing or not that's our
new tagline that's actually a [__]
insane
that's fantastic
foreign
[Music]